[Music]
good morning
tuesday morning there's a little nancy
pelosi for you
but no it's me dave rubin and this is
the reuben report direct message for
october 13
2020. as of this very moment people
today october 13th we are now three
weeks away
from the big election it's happening
three weeks from
today obviously some people have done
early voting already
dead people are voting ballots are being
chucked in the garbage
all sorts of craziness if you think it's
been nutty as i've been saying people
i got a nut factory to sell you because
it's going to get even nuttier
for the next three weeks uh we're gonna
be covering three
stories today one of them i don't know
if this is a story
a news story really or just a personal
adventure i'm going to tell you about
but on saturday this past saturday
i was driving through beverly hills and
we were on our way home
and suddenly out of nowhere there was an
absolutely
massive trump rally so we stopped and
got out
and i went to the rally with a couple
friends
and it was seriously interesting and
eye-opening i've never been to a trump
rally
so we're going to play a little video
i'm going to show you a picture tell you
a little bit about
what went down at the rally the second
story we're going to cover today
is uh well it's it's breaking right this
very second
which is that the confirmation hearing
for amy coney barrett
uh is happening right now and you know
the senators are all asking very serious
questions and it's a
serious thing that's happening of course
she will be
confirmed we know that the numbers are
there so it's just sort of
all theater and you know everyone is
doing the usual oh i believe this four
years ago but i believe this now
and rgb's dying wish was that trump not
to
not to nominate somebody and it's like
yeah we're not
governed by wishes we're governed by the
constitution which is i know very
upsetting to a lot of people
so we're going to talk about that and
then we're going to talk about this
other thing which you may have heard but
there was an nba season
i didn't watch any of it and apparently
the los angeles lakers and lebron james
won the championship on saturday night
and then
all hell broke loose downtown near the
staples center here in la
and i guess coronavirus has been solved
because thousands
and thousands of people were out there
many of them without masks and they were
celebrating by you know destroying cars
and
cracking windows and you know beating
people and all sorts of stuff it was
very exciting
and somehow nobody in the mainstream
media seems to want to call this a super
spreader event
uh but you know if uh if 10 people try
to go to church it's a super spreader so
uh so we're going to talk about that
before we get to it guys uh today's
direct message
is brought to you by the good people
of built bar and i got to tell you
something i
as you know i'm very into fitness as you
know
i do try to do cardio every day and i
lift a couple times a week
uh so the biltbar people sent me uh a
couple cases of billbar and
it's actually pretty freaking delicious
some of you know i'm a big
i'm a big peanut butter guy uh the built
bar is a new protein bar that tastes
like a candy bar it really does um
they're super tasty they come in 18
flavors my personal favorite as i just
said
is the peanut butter they're 100 covered
in chocolate and include both
nut and nut free flavors and are soft
and easy to chew
you know a lot of these bars you chew
them and they kind of taste like they're
like gritty and whatever this is smooth
and delicious and with halloween coming
around the corner
it's easy to slip up which is why built
bars are the perfect alternative to
candy for the health conscious guy
i can actually lose or maintain weight
while indulging in a delicious treat
built bars are low calorie low sugar
high protein
and high fiber and the peanut butter one
you're getting 20 gs of protein
170 calories three gs of sugar that's
that's pretty paleo-ish
uh three net carbs go to biltbar.com and
use promo code ruben
and i'll get you 20 off your first order
use promo code ruben for 20 off
at buildbar.com good for bars built go
or build boost and now back to me
all right so this saturday i was driving
through beverly hills with a couple
friends
and off santa monica drive we suddenly
started hearing a ton of
cars honking horns people screaming next
thing you know
big trump flags and american flags
everywhere and back the blue flags and
people all over the place
and i was like well we are going to stop
at this thing i have never been to a
trump rally i've seen them on tv i've
seen
people yell mean things to jim acosta at
trump rallies and i wanted to go see i
wanted to see could it be a
white supremacist rally here in los
angeles what's happening
so we we pulled over it actually was not
easy to get parking because there were
so many people there so we had to
park i don't know maybe like six blocks
away and then walk over there
and the second i got out of my car some
some guy walking with the big american
flag oh dave ruben how you doing what's
going on okay man
said hi to him we walk over there people
keep saying hi to me keep saying hi
which was
not not shocking i mean i know people
know who i am but i didn't know
what type of person is at a trump rally
in l.a
it's almost like it sounds like an
oxymoron kind of
anyway i get to the rally like people
are basically mobbing me it was
it was great i love saying hi to
everybody of course and i'm taking
pictures and everything there were
hundreds of people with flags
and with signs and they're having a ball
and you're not going to believe this
guys there were white people
there were black people there were
latino people
straight people gay people there might
have been a trans person i don't know
there were all sorts of people and
nobody
cared there were happy people like
everybody was joking around and happy
and having fun and there were i saw a
woman who had a jesus
for trump mask on and then i saw there
was a jewish guy blowing a shofar
i mean it was like it was everything
that is great about america really was
there
like putting aside whatever your
feelings may or may not be about donald
trump like this group of people that
showed up there
was just spectacular and and it was just
great i took a whole bunch of pictures
with people
and the reason i'm mentioning this is
because it wasn't
just that these people were there and it
was a truly diverse crowd in terms of
diversity of skin color and the rest of
it
um but the shocking part to me was not
that i suppose that some people could
show up for a trump rally in la in and
of itself
the shocking part was that they were had
signs like honk if you support trump as
people were driving by now we're on
santa monica boulevard this is one of
the main thruways
of beverly hills it basically is the
center
of the center of los angeles and it's
right by rodeo drive and all the fancy
stores which many of them were destroyed
by the tolerant good people of black
lives matter and antifa
um but the amount of people
that were honking as they were driving
by and you got to keep in mind these are
people in la who did not expect i don't
think there would be a trump rally
right out of nowhere and they're honking
and thumbs up
and it was like this is actually
happening
in l.a it was it was quite shocking so
anyway we had a blast there it turns out
the organizer someone introduced me to
the organizer and it turns out that
they've been doing this for the last
couple weeks
and of course she's been attacked as
being a racist and had some incidences
people you know trying to like get her
booted from her apartment complex and
all sorts of nonsense
they they do it every saturday uh right
in the heart of beverly hills so if any
of you are in la you might want to just
go check it out
um but you know the point is that when
when these things are happening
the media either ignores them right like
i don't think
cnn or msnbc or anybody's covering the
trump rally in l.a even though you'd
think that would just be like an
interesting slice of life story wow
hundreds if not thousands of people show
up to a trump rally in l.a
a lot of support on the street like are
there any biden
rallies like i mean i genuinely mean
this
someone please send me a video of a
biden rally every now and again you see
like four people holding up
a biden sign and some campaign surrogate
comes out or biden comes out
and you know forgets what state he's in
or whatever it is
um but what struck me was
the joy and happiness and fun that was
there
and like truly the love of america that
was there
versus well a there are no biden rallies
as i'm saying there just aren't we're
just like spontaneously people get
together to support biden they just
don't exist
but even when we've seen you know like
some you know the blm rallies
or the antifa rally protests murder
sessions whatever they are
like think about the anger and hostility
and that no one would carry an american
flag there or anything else it just
really does show you how
the two sides really have veered off
and what i think everyone has to do
right now if you're if you're going to
be a functioning citizen in america
is look at these two things and go which
one of these things
is closer to something that i want to be
part of
a future that i want to live in and i
think it's becoming obvious and i just
you know if you're one of the people
that's you know going oh but the polls
say this
or the experts say this it's like they
got it all wrong last time and i'm
pretty sure they're gonna get it
all wrong this time maybe i'm wrong
maybe i'm not but anyway it was it was
just
it was just a happy fun event and that's
counter to the narrative that you would
hear
that donald trump is supported by white
supremacists and the rest of it
there were three young black girls ran
up to me and said hi and oh they watch
the show and everything one of them had
a shirt
it just said you ain't black mean and
which was sort of like the take off of
biden's line you ain't black if you
don't vote for me and it's just like
man nobody cares about that stuff nobody
cares about that stuff so anyway if you
happen to be in la next saturday they do
this every week
in uh in beverly hills uh all right
let's move on to
some of the stuff that's happening in
the world right at this very moment so
as we're doing this
right now acb
acb we went from rgb now we've got acb
uh the confirmation hearings are
happening in the senate
and uh i want to play you a little bit
of her opening remarks
uh this is actually from yesterday these
are some of her opening remarks and she
says something that i think is
is pretty interesting and important
let's take a look more than the style of
his writing though
it was the content of justice scalia's
reasoning that shaped me
his judicial philosophy was
straightforward
a judge must apply the law as it is
written
not as she wishes it were
sometimes that approach meant reaching
results that he did not like
but as he put it in one of his best
known opinions
that is what it means to say that we
have a government of laws
and not of men in every case
i have carefully considered the
arguments presented by the parties
discussed the issues with my colleagues
on the court
and don my utmost to reach the result
required by the law
whatever my own preferences might be
okay so the line there that i
that i think is particularly important i
want to read it back to you exactly is
a judge must apply the law as written
not as the judge wishes it were
sometimes that approach meant reaching
results that he did not like and of
course she's talking about
former now deceased supreme court
justice antonin scalia
what's interesting about that is i think
it sums up so much of
what is sort of wrong with the dialogue
the whole thing at the moment
which is that a lot of people just want
things to be a certain way because they
feel it should be a certain way
they feel they're right and it should
just be a certain way
and that they're going to make it happen
under any circumstances which is why
there is such
a feeling of just burn it all down and
and just in the last couple days we've
seen
even more statues torn down and i think
it was in portland yesterday
a statue of abraham lincoln was taken
down
call me crazy people i thought i thought
abraham lincoln was one of the good guys
i mean not only did he free the slaves
but
you know killed all those vampires i
mean the guy has done a lot of stuff
right so
uh but but that feeling of oh i just
want something to be a certain way
so if i don't get it i can burn
everything down which as you guys know
i've
often liken this to what cobra did in gi
joe when their plan wasn't working every
gi joe ended with cobra commander
destroying
the whole thing if i can't have it
nobody can and that's sort of
what the modern left has become a judge
must apply to law
as written not as the judge wishes it
were now
what that means is that you look at the
laws
you look at the constitution you look at
the bill of rights
and you say what has been written here
and then if you want to amend
the constitution there are ways to go
about amending it
not everything should be done by
executive action and you guys know my
feelings on all those things so anyway
there was a really beautiful moment this
morning
during the hearings where one of the
senators is
looking at her a male senator so this is
automatically mansplaining or is it
mansplaining
when it's a republican woman being
talked to or is that only when it's a
democratic woman it's very confusing how
this mansplaining thing works
but he's sitting there and he's got a
lot of papers in front of him and books
and all sorts of information and his
people have obviously prepared him very
intensely
and and he says well acb
what do you got in front of you and she
picks up a piece of paper
and she's literally got nothing on it i
mean this is going to be the meme of the
day for sure because people are going to
be writing all sorts of funny things on
it
but it's just got you know like the
letterhead from the senate or something
like that there's just nothing on it so
that means she's just sitting there
basically answering their questions off
the top of her head so
look people have asked me my feelings on
acb
um my general feeling is that her
quote right there is all you can ask
a judge to do that the the law is what
is written
not what you feel and so this is all
sort of theater when they're doing these
confirmation hearings and they're trying
to get her feelings
about obamacare or they're trying to get
her feelings
about abortion or these other things if
a case makes it all the way to the
supreme court that has to do with the
affordable care act obamacare
or has to do with abortion which
ultimately would be roe v wade
or any of these other things then
it's clear that what she's saying is my
judicial philosophy
is i will look at what the law says and
that's how i will apply it that's very
much in line with scalia
and in effect so she's sort of the the
replacement
for scalia that does mean the court will
lean a little
more to the conservative side obviously
because
rgb obviously was a little more on the
liberal side
but all of these people that say this is
the republicans packing the court and
everything else it's like
trump did win the presidency they
haven't accepted it but trump did win
the presidency
and then the republicans have the senate
that is
that is just the truth so it's not
packing everyone
everyone is doing their job and i read a
quote to you guys about two weeks ago
rgb from a couple years ago was saying
well that the president is supposed to
serve
uh for four years he doesn't serve for
three years or he doesn't serve for
three years and eight months he serves
for four years
so everything that you're watching right
now i mean you probably shouldn't spend
that much time watching c-span right now
because it's all theater she's going to
be confirmed
and and i just want to say one other
thing on this because i hear a lot of
people saying but
but dave you know her record with gays
she's gonna they're gonna flip the gay
marriage they're coming for the gays
they only i mean they keep telling me
they're coming for you it is i don't
know of an instance in the history of
the united states where the supreme
court
has decided to take rights away from
people
think of the crazed pandora's box that
would open up
if they tried to actually take rights
away from people
you're going to nullify all these
marriages you're going to kick it all
back to the states the legal craziness
on top of the fact that the country has
moved on this is like saying oh they're
going to take away women's right to vote
or they're going to take away black
people's right to vote it just
is not happening the ship has sailed and
and it's consistent with everything that
we've done in the united states with
states which is that we've
spread more equality to more people
i don't think a court that suddenly you
say leaning
a little more to the right is suddenly
gonna
you know basically say okay now we can
take rights away
from people um i also think justice
stevens who was the deciding vote on on
the gay marriage case
you know his idea of equal protection
under the law that was what his argument
was that
all people in essence should be treated
equally under the law i think we can all
agree with that
that it seems like that would be pretty
hard to overturn so i think everyone can
calm down about that if you can find one
thing to calm down about i would say
that's it
anyway we'll find out what happens over
the next couple days but let's move on
to the third story because there was an
nba
season i did not watch it you know my
feelings on this
i just do not need to be lectured by
millionaires about politics when i'm
trying to watch sports worse which are
supposed to be an escape from politics
the nba ratings have been absolutely
disastrous all season and then the
finals ratings were down by about
55 from last year and something like 70
since last time lebron is in it now just
try to
if you're just a basketball person just
try to back up for a second lebron is is
the modern michael jordan
every time michael jordan was in the
finals the ratings were
absolutely bananas and the guy did
amazing things to the point where people
who weren't necessarily huge basketball
fans
just wanted to tune in for that but this
year you know you've got
messages social justice messages on the
back of players jerseys you've got black
lives matter on the court
and people people have just had it they
they are just sick of it
there's been this ongoing battle between
clay travis of outkick.com who's been on
the show many times
and is a buddy of mine and mark cuban
who's the the billionaire
shark tank guy also owns the dallas
mavericks they've been fighting
for a while now on twitter um because
clay is basically saying hey go woke go
broke this is th this is the proof is in
the pudding
right like it's all right here we're
looking at the ratings and mark cuban
refuses
to accept it it's it's kind of like well
actually the proof is in the pudding
because even david silver
who is the commissioner of the nba is
saying
hey guys we're not going to be doing the
social justice thing next year so it's
either
that he didn't think it was a big deal
this you know
the white supremacy spreading throughout
the united states or whatever it is
he obviously didn't think it was a big
deal or he looked at the numbers and he
was like whoa
we are actually burning our own house
down
and if you guys all want to be paid the
millions and millions and millions of
dollars right lebron you want that 15
15 million dollar a year check or
whatever he gets plus the endorsements
and all those things well we actually
can't alienate our fan base
because we do need people to actually
watch this thing
and especially in a time of corona as
we're playing in a bubble and there's no
people here so we're losing all that
money like
it still is a business well in any event
the lakers did win the nba championship
apparently they played the miami heat i
did not watch
a moment of it although i was on uh on
the roof
uh having a drink having a little glass
of wine on saturday night we suddenly
heard
all of these uh all these fireworks
throughout la so we did realize that the
lakers had won it was either that or
an impending invasion from china and i
just felt
it was probably that the lakers won uh
and then there's some incredible video
we're gonna play it for you right now
this is this is
downtown uh right outside the staples
center
right after the lakers won the
championship
and as you can see coronavirus has been
[Music]
solved
all right there it is people i didn't
see anyone
uh on cnn on msnbc any of the new york
times journalists or anybody else
calling this a super spreader event
so i guess corona's been solved now uh
you know if
if 10 jews in brooklyn uh want to
celebrate a holiday that seems to be a
problem
and if 15 people in omaha want to go to
a church that seems to be a problem but
apparently thousands of people
in the streets you know attacking police
cars i think about 30
stores had their windows broken you know
just all the usual stuff that we now see
virtually every day for virtually any
reason
uh there were a couple arrests it sounds
like there were about 80 arrests and the
rest of it
but the point is the the stupidity the
stupidity
of the way the media treats us where
it's like they either won't
show you that like that doesn't make it
to mainstream news really like showing
people what happened because then it
would show
their obvious hypocrisy so yesterday
trump was doing a campaign rally and
there were
as usual there were thousands of people
there and uh
what's his name jim acosta cnn's main
clown
he's there and he's got the mask on okay
that's fine and he's talking about how
some of the people have masks and some
of the people don't and then the crowd
starts cheering that
cnn sucks and jim acosta sucks it's it's
pretty funny
but it's like he's talking about
basically these people without masks
there and it's true they're at an
outdoor event and some of the people
don't have masks
i don't know at that specific event what
the campaign decided to do whether you
all had to have your temperature checked
or not
or whatever but people have made a
choice for themselves and you can
you can judge them for that choice and
that's just fine but people are making a
choice for themselves
yet they'll mock those people in essence
that's what acosta is doing right and
back to you wolf it's these people
aren't wearing masks back to you wolf
and it's like okay we're going to mock
these people but we're not even going to
show you or comment on the fact that
thousands and thousands of masculist
people were
jam-packed in the streets in la because
that really can't spin that to be
anti-trump
and and it's this asymmetrical warfare
that i actually think in many ways is is
becoming a bigger issue than
the political thing itself in many ways
this election
will come down to a referendum on the
media
and do people trust it anymore and
for all the talk of fake news four years
ago
i think the amount of people that have
woken up
to that have gone basically from woke to
awake as i like to say
is there's just no way of gauging it
it's not going to show up in
any polls and anything else but when you
show
that you know you're allowed to riot in
the streets and you're allowed to burn
down buildings and all of that if your
anti-fun black lives matter
but then if you're in brooklyn and
you're a bunch of jews trying to
celebrate a holiday that's a problem but
the
other one's okay or just the way the
media treats it not even just the way
law enforcement treats it
or that if you're at a trump rally cnn
is going to call you out for not wearing
a mask but then they're not even going
to show you the video of what's
happening
los angeles downtown because those are
not trump supporters basically
um it's that disconnect it's that sort
of
fake news disconnect that i think is the
problem and
i'm sure i assume that at least some of
you read my book and one of the things i
talk about is the four types
of fake news and one type of fake news
is that
it's not just when they show you a
headline
that doesn't match the story or or the
headline is of complete fabrication
those are the obvious types of fake news
but one of the types of fake news
is the things that they won't show you
because they don't fit the narrative
and it's like i tweeted that that video
i tweeted out it got something like 50
000 retweets or something and then i
tweeted
i tweeted it at acosta and it got
another 10 000 or something it's like so
this guy
sees this i even said i'd buy him a
cookie my tweet said
jim acosta i'll buy you a cookie if you
share this video but of course they
won't of course they won't because they
they like
narrative uh more than truth
and that leaves me doing a show like
this so if anything
i thank you wolf blitzer i thank you jim
acosta
i thank you don lemon anyway guys three
weeks from today is the big election
uh we will be covering everything as it
unfolds there was supposed to be a
debate this week then they wanted to do
it virtually trump backed out hopefully
there'll be a debate next week but yeah
it's going to be a crazy couple weeks
so stay tuned for more and i look
forward to sharing
information with you as it comes across
my desk
and my crack notes which are right here